du côté de l'économie à présent avec
l'explosion de la dette publique une
autre conséquence de l'épidémie
coronavirus les milliards de soutien à
l'économie propulse l'endettement de la
france à des niveaux record alors dans
quelle mesure cette dette est-elle
gérable faudra-t-il un jour rembourser
tout cet argent on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
jacques bonsoir bienvenue
bonsoir olivier alors j'accepte d'être
qui explose
est ce que c'est vraiment grave docteur
alors oui la dette explose ça c'est
absolument incontestable on était à 98%
à la fin de 2018
on va être autour de 120% à la fin de
cette année en même temps il faut
toujours dire que les taux d'intérêt
sont très bas ils sont en partie
négative par exemple pour la france et
d'autres pays ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
certains pays comme l'italie et
l'espagne
remettent en cause le fameux plan d'aidé
européen qui avait été décidé en juillet
tout simplement parce que ils
considèrent qu'ils n'ont aucun intérêt
de s'endetter auprès de l'union
européenne
ils préfèrent aller directement sur les
marchés où ils auront de l'argent
beaucoup moins cher et puis il ya une
troisième chose dont il faut se souvenir
ce n'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire et même dans l'histoire
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale que
nous avons un taux de dette par rapporté
au pib qui est extrêmement élevé on
avait un taux déjà très élevé après 1945
et on s'en est sorti sans aucune
sincérité
donc je pense que il ne faut pas trop
s'inquiéter et il faut regarder je
dirais de manière raisonnable cette
question de la dette alors jacques où en
est un label public aujourd'hui
alors la dette publique augmente pour
plusieurs raisons
première raison c'est que les ressources
de l'état diminuent le pipe diminue nous
allons avoir une contraction entre -9 et
-12% du pub plutôt maintenant vers l'est
les moins 10 -12 que vers les mois 9
donc évidemment il ya des recettes en
moins dans le même temps il ya des
dépenses en plus il ya eu toutes les
mesures de soutien à l'économie
elles sont été prises il ya le fameux
plan de relance donc ça veut dire qu'il
y à une impasse budgétaire et qui ne
cesse de croître
et comme dans le fameux rapport dette
sur pibe le dénominateur le pibe diminue
et bien évidemment nous allons atteindre
un niveau historiquement élevé
je vous dis autour de 120% de ce ratio
dette sur pib
mais ce ratio au monde de manière quasi
inexorable depuis des années oui tout à
fait tout à fait on était en 74 quand
valéry giscard d'estaing a été élu on
était autour de 15 % de la dette par
rapport au pib
on a atteint les 60% en 2002 si vous
voulez lors de la réélection de jacques
chirac alors après ce que l'on voit en
particulier sur ce graphique c'est que
avec la crise de 2008 2010 il ya eu une
première il ya une nouvelle plutôt
augmentation importante de la dette que
cela ne s'est pas arrêté en dépit ou
peut-être du fait des mesures
d'austérité qu'ils avaient été décidés
d'abord par françois fillon puis ensuite
les mesures qui ont été prises dans le
quinquennat de françois hollande
mais par contre que l'on voit aussi très
bien c'est que la dette s'envole
complètement depuis grosso modo six mois
mais cette dette il faudra bien un jour
ou l'autre la payer non alors c'est un
autre problème
si vous voulez les états rembourse
excessivement rarement leurs dettes
alors il peut faire défaut sur les
intérêts ou sur le principal ça c'est
une chose
ils peuvent et c'est ce qu'ils font
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus fréquemment ils
empruntent pour rembourser une partie de
la dette est ce qu'on appelle faire
rouler la dette
et puis il ya une autre méthode les
banques centrales peuvent se décider
d'eux
racheter la dette alors la bce là un
petit peu fait mais historiquement les
banques centrales nationales l'ons
beaucoup fait donc en réalité il y à des
méthodes importante pour gérer une dette
publique
alors je vous propose jacques de revenir
un peu en arrière vous avez dit que la
france a déjà connu dans son histoire
des dettes énormes alors commençons
était le débarrasser effectivement il
faut se rappeler qu'en 1945 à la fin de
la guerre du fait d'abord d'une
production qui était très basse à cause
de toutes les destructions
on avait atteint grosso modo 270 % par
rapport au pic de dette par rapport au
pib
qu'est ce qui s'est passé justement est
bien à l'époque il faut rappeler que le
trésor contrôler assez étroitement la
banque de france et donc la banque de
france
acheter des bons du trésor elle les
acheter directement trésor ce qu'on
appelait le système des avances à l'état
ou des avances au trésor et donc on a eu
un double phénomène
on a eu de tout d'abord un phénomène de
forte croissance alors ça a été
évidemment la reconstruction mais il ya
eu un aussi un phénomène de croissance
lié à la modernisation de l'économie
française à ce qu'on appelle en histoire
les trente glorieuses et en même temps
il ya eu un phénomène d'inflation qui
était relativement important donc ça
veut dire que le pib nominal a augmenté
de manière extrêmement rapide alors que
la dette elle stagné ou augmenter et
relativement peu et donc c'est comme
cela que l'on est passé des 270 % dans
l'immédiate après guerre à un taux de
l'ordre de 14,1 14,7 au début des années
70 après ce qui est intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il faut savoir que à
ce moment là au début des années 70
les économistes de l'époque considéré
c'est ce que l'on m'a appris quand je
faisais mes études d'économie
que le taux de dette était trop faible
pour la france pourquoi parce que les
dettes publiques les bons du trésor
servait à alimenter un mécanisme de
financement et de refinancement des
banques commerciales et donc c'est pour
cela que le gouvernement en 1973 a
décidé de suspendre le système des
avances de la banque de france au trésor
mais c'était uniquement de manière à
faire monter un petit peu je dirais ce
taux de manière à permettre justement
aux banques de se refinancer
mais pas que aujourd'hui la france est
l'un des pays les plus endettés de
l'union européenne alors elle ne l'était
pas tant que ça au début de la décennie
ou même si on regarde un petit peu avant
disons autour des années 2006 2008
on voit que la france se situe à peu de
choses près dans la moyenne de l'union
européenne mais à partir de là crise de
2008-2010 et bien on voit que le taux de
dette montrent de manière importante
commence à se séparer de la moyenne de
l'union européenne
et alors ce qui est très intéressant il
ya des pays qui ont toujours eu des taux
de dette important par exemple l'italie
mais on voit que des pays comme
l'espagne comme le royaume uni qui
avaient en réalité un taux de dette qui
était relativement faible
avant la crise de 2008 2010 eh bien ces
pays rejoignent tout d'un coup la france
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que en réalité le problème de la dette
publique
c'est une des conséquences de la crise
financière de 2008 2010 une crise
financière qui en réalité n'a jamais été
digéré par les économies européennes
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas un problème
spécifiquement français finalement
c'est une question qu'on peut qu'on peut
se poser c'est ce qui est important
c'est de regarder à ce moment là la
totalité de l'endettement en france
alors bien sûr il ya la dette publique
mais il ya aussi la dette des ménages et
la dette des entreprises
hélas si vous voulez ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que en matière
de dette publique et bien en 2008 on
était à peu près au même niveau que
l'allemagne
on était supérieur à la grande-bretagne
très inférieures à l'italie et que au
niveau de la dette totale
on était aussi un des pays les moins
endettés en europe
par contre si on regarde les
statistiques de 2018
on voit d'une part que la dette publique
elle est relativement importante là nous
sommes au dessus de la grande bretagne
nous sommes très au-dessus de
l'allemagne certes sommes toujours en
dessous de l'it animaux mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir que la
dea total en france
là elle a quasiment explosé par rapport
à l'allemagne on sait on à décrocher par
rapport à l'allemagne
et on est tout à fait au niveau de
l'italie du royaume uni qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que il ya en
france un problème spécifique
d'endettement en partie des ménages mais
surtout d'endettement des entreprises et
cela se conjugue évidemment avec le
phénomène de la dette publique
alors quel avenir pour cette dette qui
va donc gonfler avec des taux d'intérêt
historiquement bas
bon honnêtement si on regarde la dette
publique
je ne vois pas de gros problèmes à
l'horizon que ce soit la banque centrale
européenne où que ce soit les banques
centrales nationales les banques
centrales rachèteront une partie de la
dette et donc d'une certaine manière ça
ne pèsera pas sur les épaules du
gouvernement par contre ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que quand on a dans
différents pays des niveaux de dettes
aux ménages de dette par les ménages ou
de dettes des entreprises qui sont
élevés et bien évidemment il y a une
tendance inévitable à vouloir que la
dette publique reprenne une partie cet
endettement
d'ailleurs ce que l'on fait actuellement
si vous voulez avec toutes les garanties
publiques aux dettes privées qui ont été
prises pour lutter contre le risque de
récession fin contre la récession réelle
en réalité qui est liée à la copie de 19
eh bien ça va nécessairement un moment
donné se traduire par un transfert des
dettes privées donc d'être des ménages
est d'être des entreprises vers la dette
publique et là ça va poser un problème
parce que en europe il ya des pays qui
disent vous pouvez pas faire ça ce n'est
pas dans les règles européennes puis à
des pays qui vont dire non il faut le
faire parce qu'autrement nos économies
s'écroule et c'est donc plutôt dans
l'ain gestion à moyen terme d'ici deux
trois ans que la question de la dette
globale et de la dette publique
évidemment risque de se poser avec une
très grande acuité et bien jacques voilà
qui pourrait s'avérer intéressant à
suivre dans les mois qui viennent merci
jacques